[Aplausos]
[Música]
hollywood es el barrio más famoso del
mundo y si habéis oído bien he dicho
barrio hollywood no es una ciudad ni
siquiera un pueblo se trata de un
distrito dentro de la ciudad de los
ángeles con menos de 90 mil habitantes
sin embargo es aquí donde se concentran
la mayor parte de las productoras de
cine a nivel internacional
y si ya sé lo que me vais a decir
fonseca eso no es cierto
en realidad el lugar que más películas
produce en todo el mundo es bollywood en
la india pues si tenéis razón pero hay
un detalle que se os escapa aunque la
industria del cine hindú produzca más
títulos que ninguna otra el dinero que
generan es prácticamente una broma
comparada con los ingresos de hollywood
[Música]
pensadlo bien habéis visto muchas
películas de la india pues probablemente
no salvo unas pocas excepciones casi
todas las películas del cine de
bollywood se venden únicamente en la
india y lo mismo ocurre con nigeria por
si no lo sabéis
nigeria es el segundo productor de cine
en todo el planeta pero estoy seguro de
que pocos habéis visto alguna película
hecha en este país es decir que en
términos económicos hollywood es la
capital indiscutible del cine
[Música]
y os preguntaréis por qué os vamos a
hablar de cine en visual políti que
tiene que ver este canal con las
películas pues mucho porque el hecho de
que la industria del entretenimiento
esté concentrada en esta zona tan
específica del mundo tiene una
explicación política a fin de cuentas
porque los ángeles es la capital del
cine y no lo es londres o nueva york
muchos pensaréis que california siempre
ha sido un estado importante dentro de
eeuu con empresas innovadoras
universidades de prestigio y famosos
paseando por las calles
pero lo cierto es que a principios del
siglo 20 los ángeles apenas tenían 100
mil habitantes de hecho las primeras
productoras de cine nacieron en el otro
extremo del país concretamente en nueva
york' así que la pregunta es por qué
decidieron mudarse a los ángeles que
tenía hollywood que no tuviera manhattan
y lo que es más importante sigue siendo
hollywood la meca del cine hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
arte por y para los inmigrantes la
primera pregunta que nos tenemos que
hacer es quién inventó el cine los
hermanos lumière pues no exactamente lo
que inventaron los hermanos lumière fue
el sistema para proyectar películas en
una gran sala pero años atrás la empresa
de thomas alva edison ya había
descubierto un sistema para poder grabar
y reproducir películas cortas el
kinetoscopio
[Música]
se trataba de una máquina donde metías
una moneda y podías ver imágenes en
movimiento a través de un visor años
después
edison mejoró el invento para que
también pudiera proyectar imágenes en
una sala y a diferencia de los hermanos
lumière edison tenía muy claro que el
cine era algo más que un descubrimiento
científico era un negocio
no quiero inventar cosas que no se
venden las ventas son una prueba de la
utilidad y la utilidad es sinónimo de
éxito
thomas alva edison mientras los lumière
se limitaron a mostrar su invento por
diferentes ferias internacionales
edison se dedicó a venderlo su negocio
consistía en vender máquinas cobrar una
comisión por utilizarlas y además
suministrar de películas a todos los
teatros edison llegó a producir más de
1200 películas
y os preguntaréis qué tipo de cine vez
día el señor edison a sus clientes pues
por sorprendente que os parezca las
primeras películas comerciales
consistían en señoritas quitándose la
ropa tal cual como lo oís sin embargo el
cine daba mucho más de sí
en pocos años ciudades como nueva york o
chicago se llenaron de salas de cine
los llamados nickelodeon aquí te
prometían diversión a un precio mucho
más barato que cualquier otro
espectáculo de teatro además como eran
películas mudas no necesitabas saber
inglés para entenderlas eso significa
que el cine se convirtió en el
pasatiempo perfecto para todos esos
muchísimos inmigrantes que llegaban al
país de las oportunidades
estamos ya en la primera década del
siglo 20 francia y curiosamente
dinamarca ya tenían productoras de cine
pero ningún otro país tenía tantísimo
público como eeuu
sin embargo thomas alva edison era
incapaz de ver las oportunidades que
tenía su invento
a fin de cuentas se trataba del clásico
estadounidense blanco y anglosajón que
en cierto modo despreciaba a todos esos
inmigrantes por supuesto estaba
encantado de ganar dinero gracias a
ellos pero para qué iba a invertir en
producir películas de calidad cuando a
fin de cuentas su empresa tenía el
monopolio de la producción y
distribución de cines cualquiera de esos
nickelodeon pagaba sus royalties a la
empresa de edison y después compraban
rollos de películas prácticamente al
peso sin siquiera mirar los argumentos
ni los títulos
a fin de cuentas nadie pensaba que esos
inmigrantes alemanes húngaros o
italianos iban a apreciar muchos matices
hasta que apareció este señor que veis
en la pantalla
carl lewis
[Música]
deming era uno de esos inmigrantes
alemanes que tenía un nickelodeon en
chicago el negocio le iba
maravillosamente bien pero estaba
cansado de tener que pagar tantísimo
dinero por las películas de ellison así
que se preguntó podría hacer yo mis
propias películas y como decíamos en
visual político dicho y hecho
[Música]
lenny conocía a otros propietarios de
salas todos ellos eran inmigrantes que
conocían bien los gustos y las
aspiraciones de su público sabían que el
cine podía ser algo más que chistes
malos y señoritas ligeras de ropa
podrían crear auténticas estrellas como
esas actrices famosas que salían en los
musicales de broadway estos pioneros del
cine fueron los primeros en poner los
nombres de los actores en los carteles
de las películas y en los títulos de
crédito
de esta forma conseguían que muchos
otros actores quisieran trabajar con
ellos sus películas se hicieron famosas
en un público que venía de distintos
países del mundo y por eso a esta
productora la llamaron la productora
universal lay universal
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar el éxito de esta
nueva empresa sirvió de inspiración para
muchas otras pequeñas productoras por
ejemplo otro inmigrante húngaro adolfo
ducó también se asoció con otros dueños
de salas de cine y formó otra productora
la paramount pictures
[Música]
de repente nueva york y en general la
costa este de eeuu se estaba
convirtiendo en una especie de hollywood
primitivo pero esperad un momento porque
thomas alva edison no estaba dispuesto a
perder la batalla no olvidéis que era él
quien tenía la fama el dinero y las
patentes para que os hagáis una idea en
menos de cinco años
lemmy y sus socios tuvieron que
enfrentarse a más de 200 demandas
judiciales
y muchas de éstas pequeñas productoras
que habían surgido tuvieron que echar el
cierre por no poder hacer frente a todas
las demandas que presentaba la empresa
de ericsson eran malos tiempos para los
productoras pero sin duda fue una época
dorada para los abogados
por si esto fuera poco edison tenía
poder suficiente como para obligar a
todos esos nickelodeon es de nueva york
y chicago a firmar contratos de
exclusividad si querían utilizar la
tecnología de edison no podían comprar
las películas de la competencia
y fue en ese momento cuando nuestro
amigo karl emmy se preguntó y quién me
manda a seguir en la costa este edison
era un hombre poderoso sí pero su sombra
no llegaba a todas partes había un lugar
alejado de su órbita de influencia y ese
lugar se llamaba california
el nacimiento de una industria en 1915
california era un sitio donde estaba
todo por hacer
miles de jóvenes inmigrantes que
recordar que era el público perfecto
para los cines llegaban cada año las
casas y el suelo eran sustancialmente
más baratos que en cualquier otra parte
de eeuu y por si esto fuera poco el
clima era fantástico en nuevayork llueve
cada dos por tres así que si quieres
rodar películas tienes que hacerlo en un
estudio y gastarte miles de dólares en
focos en california sin embargo puedes
rodar en exteriores en cualquier época
del año
en otras palabras california era el
lugar perfecto para crear una productora
y por eso todas estas empresas de nueva
york y chicago se asentaron en un barrio
en las afueras de los ángeles un
suburbio de poco más de 500 habitantes
que se llamaba hollywood
[Música]
y os preguntaréis cómo es posible que el
cine de california el cine de hollywood
llegará a conquistar las audiencias del
mundo entero no olvidéis que por aquel
entonces eeuu todavía no era la potencia
hegemónica que sería más tarde además
países como francia o dinamarca ya
tenían sus propias productoras de cine
así que porque hollywood logró la fama
internacional tan pronto
[Música]
la respuesta está en el llamado efecto
red los que están suscritos a visual
polític nos habréis oído hablar de este
fenómeno mil veces en otras palabras
todos estos estudios que había en
hollywood sirvieron como un imán para
atraer a inversores y profesionales de
todo el mundo
eso explica que en 1915 hollywood fuera
el escenario de la primera
superproducción de la historia el
nacimiento de una nación que llegó a
costar alrededor de 100 mil dólares de
la época por cierto que fue una película
extremadamente polémica porque
básicamente los buenos son el ku kux
klan pero eso es otra historia lo cierto
es que en poco más de 10 años la
población de hollywood creció en más de
30 mil habitantes en su mayoría eran
inmigrantes como por ejemplo francisco
elías
[Música]
y este español llegó a eeuu para
trabajar como ayudante de producción y
enseguida se dio cuenta de una cosa si
traducía al español los cartelitos que
aparecían en las películas podía
exportar cine a españa y latinoamérica y
al igual que el muchos otros inmigrantes
se dedicaron a traducir las películas a
sus lenguas maternas de repente el cine
de hollywood se podía entender en todo
el mundo pero esperad un momento porque
ya sé lo que estáis pensando qué pasó
cuando se inventó el cine sonoro pues
precisamente este fue el auténtico punto
de inflexión en la industria del cine
estadounidense
outlaw y os voy a poner un ejemplo en la
alemania de hitler el gobierno invirtió
auténticas fortunas en subvencionar a
sus productoras de cine y por supuesto
estas empresas intentaban exportar sus
películas a los países aliados países
como la españa de franco que durante los
años 40
del tercer reich sin embargo casi
ninguna sala de cine española llegó a
proyectar películas alemanas porque pues
porque estas productoras alemanas apenas
contaban con la tecnología necesaria
para doblar las películas en cambio
hollywood contaba con montones de
startups que se habían encargado de
desarrollar los mejores sistemas de
doblaje
[Música]
el maestro además al tener tantísima
población inmigrante era extremadamente
fácil contar con traductores y actores e
incluso algunas productoras llegaron a
tener oficinas en países como españa
para enviar los rollos de celuloide
listos para ser reemplazados por el
audio en español tenga
si alguien pone la mano en el rocín
dispararle pero no vaya a equivocarse y
maté al facebook váyase sólo deseo que
te vaya y ojalá una bala de cañón le
acierta igual que se ha hecho en mil
pero hace falta que siga ya me doy
cuenta de sus intenciones en otras
palabras ya las películas
estadounidenses eran mucho más baratas
de proyectar que las de ningún otro país
esto unido al talento de auténticos
genios del cine como john ford que venía
de irlanda o ernest lubitsch que venía
de alemania fueron las armas definitivas
para que eeuu desbancará a cualquier
otro país en lo que respecta al cine
[Música]
you take that es decir que hollywood
nació a partir de la gente que venía
desde fuera de eeuu
y hollywood creció gracias a vender sus
películas hacia fuera de los eeuu
y por cierto aquí tengo que hacer un
paréntesis si no conocéis a john ford
haceos un favor y tratar de ver el
hombre que mató a liberty valance es
algo así como la capilla sixtina del
celuloide y no ha envejecido en absoluto
aunque esté en blanco y negro es un
consejo que os damos desde visual
político y que nos vais a agradecer
yo soy
y ahora la pregunta es qué pasó después
cómo consiguió hollywood sobrevivir a la
censura oa la piratería si queréis que
os cuente esta historia me lo podéis
decir en los comentarios mientras tanto
en este otro vídeo os contamos otra
historia de éxito la historia de apple
haced clic aquí para verlo y como
siempre no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto black out louds brisbane
[Música]
am